Ivana Lynch played Luna love good in the
franchise Who belongs to the Hogwarts
house Ravenclaw in one interview she
took the Potter more quiz to discover
her house in real life and let's just
say she was very pleased with her result
Gryffindor but also like not surprised
so while she may be a Ravenclaw on
screen she's a Gryffindor at Heart from
one star's affirming quiz result to one
that didn't come quite so easily Tom
Felton who played Draco Mal for got
competitive while taking a quiz during
an interview if anyone could Ace the
most impossible Harry Potter quiz it
would be one of the movie stars but it
was impossible after all how many Harry
Potter characters can you name in one
minute
hook um uh Dobby James Potter Lily
Potter SE snake oh Cy not as easy as it
sounds how many did I get seven Great ch